Today is about Europe's long lost medieval number system.
So for the first thousand years of the first millennium,
there was one game in town and that was Roman numerals.
Everyone knows what revenue was, are one, two, three, four,
five, et cetera. Then from the 13th century, thereabouts,
there was a new guy in town and that was Arabic numerals, which as we know,
zero one, two, three, four, five,
and for the next hundred years, there was a couple of centuries. Actually,
there's a kind of battle between who's going to win,
which is going to be the dominant number system. And as we know,
the one that won the notation that we use all over the world is the Arabic
number system. It's like much, much better. It's kind of place value.
It's got the zero, et cetera.
What almost no one knows is that in the late middle ages.
So between the 13th and the 15th century, there was a third guy in town.
This was the notation that was devised and developed and used by
the Cistercian order.
So this is a group of monks is actually the most influential religious order of
the late middle ages, but actually an offshoot, you know,
a little bit of ecclesiastical history.
They're an offshoot of the Benedictines who didn't think the Benedictines were
aesthetic enough.
It has a kind of minimalist lifestyle where it's just you and like the earth.
So what the Cistercians did is that they were really in sort of manual labor.
And as a result of that,
they actually developed lots of techniques and agriculture and architecture.
And they built up from a beginning in the mid 11th century, two,
three centuries later,
they had about more than 500 monasteries all across Europe from
the North of the British Isles,
down to the Mediterranean from Poland on one side to
Portugal and the other.
And they used amongst themselves a secret number notation.
And I want to show to you, it is like magical looking. It's kind of mysterious.
Also here it is. So I'm going to write down four numbers in Cistercian
notation.
[Inaudible].
These are four numbers. What can you make out of that? And in fact,
this is a puzzle. I call it it's a monkey puzzle.
I love that one. I haven't read it as much. It's a monkey puzzle, um,
in my new puzzle book about languages,
and this is a kind of scientific language notation book there.
That one they're very good,
especially for Christmas gifts and during lockdown for spending all your
evenings, doing all these wonderful language and number puzzles,
but you didn't make this up. This is like, this is totally true.
It's totally true. Um, there in fact,
no one really knows about it until about 20 years ago,
a historian of science called David A.
King wrote a book about it because he had realized and discovered he did his
sort of the kind of life's research on this number system.
And the book is accepted as true.
And you can see these in some of the ancient texts and this kind of secret
number system. Obviously it didn't catch on,
but it was used by various different groups for kind of medieval ciphers and
secret number systems.
So it was used even once the Cistercians stopped using it. Anyway,
I'll tell you something more about this assertion.
This assertions were brilliant.
So it was the ones are very aesthetic type of life. And so they banned speaking.
Okay. So about a thousand years ago, they a vow of silence.
You weren't allowed to speak. So they developed their own sign language.
So when the first people develop their own sign language and they used the sign
language for a thousand years and I called up the British Cistercian Abbey,
there's only one left in England and says,
do you still use this five silence sign language? And they said,
no, we don't. But some of my elder monks still understand it.
And it's so great because what they do is that they get these words and they
have to piece the meaning of the words into smaller
bits. So for example,
and also each bit is a kind of mime of what the word represents.
So what'd you think this might mean Adobe read whole
milk. This is milk cause milking the other, okay.
This is Brown. So chocolate milk.
Okay. In other one, this, that Brown, I don't know why that is Brown,
but there's a great book was written in the seventies where, um, uh,
a researcher went into one of these abbeys where they were still speaking and
took loads of pictures. I don't know dad. In fact,
there's a great puzzle about this in anyway.
So I know all about the Cistercians. They're absolutely fascinating.
Another one just very quickly. This means land or country.
What country is this?
Okay.
Drink tea land England. Yes. Brilliant.
Okay. Another one that you're liking this so much. What does this.
Bingo.
Ring? Not cool.
E O E tall E
land. It's Ellie.
Uh, okay. Let's get back to here.
So is it true?
It does look a bit like hangman or it looks a little bit like stick, man.
You could put a little sort of head there.
I'm going to give you more of a cleaner. I'm going to say what the numbers are.
This is actually 1,410.
This one is 4,173.
This one is five seven, five zero. And this one is a one, three,
six, eight. Now, do you have any more of a clue about how this works?
Uh, I mean obviously where things come off, the main STEM is important.
Yeah. Very good. Very good.
You might want to freeze it now and people can have a think because I'm about to
give the game away.
Okay. A little bit of elevator music
here.
This is one, four, one zero.
I'm going to tell you already that it's expressed as a decimal.
So the system is decimal.
We've got two ones here and these two bits look quite the same and we've got two
fives here and these two bits look the same.
So actually that's something like that is going to be like a five.
That's going to be a one.
And also that's like a one we've got one going out there. So,
but you're beginning to piece together.
This idea that these elements that are coming off rather than the sides,
the ends are the digits expressed in some way,
it is a system that can only write every number from zero to
9,999. It can't do any other numbers.
So this in fact is how you count. Zero is just the STEM.
So every number has a STEM. That is one, this is two. This is three.
This is four. Now we get funds. That's a four. So I can say zero one, two,
three, four, there's four, five as foreign ones who put the 41 together.
That's five. This is six to get to seven, which is six. And one is that eight,
which is six and two and nine, which is six and three. Is that,
that is zero to nine.
But what you see is that if you divide it into four quarters,
the units go here. This is tens. This is hundreds, and this is thousands.
So that is a 1000, that's a 400.
Then we get this one here and zero.
So briefly choose any four digit number and let's write the number. Uh,
you'll say you were born six, six, six, six, six. Well, that's going be easy.
So go to six, six, six, six. It's going to be six, six,
six, six. It looks quite good. It looks like a, um,
a quad bike signal from above.
How about 20, 20, 20, 20 would be two. So it's that?
And zero and then two. And then there's that,
but how about say 1969 is zeros born best years. Okay.
So 19.
So it would be a one here and it will be a nine and then there'll be a
six and then a nine. Nice. It's quite fun. Isn't it?
Wouldn't be very useful for things like mathematics. Like if I said add
3,472 to whatever, like.
No, but what be really cool and really easy.
And where it was used by the Cistercians is for dates because dates have four
digits. So it's like brilliant w for my puzzle book where I put this in,
I wanted the publisher to actually put the date in the opening page written and
substation notation. But I was told that quite latte,
but another thing where it is good and it is often used,
it was used by the Cistercians was for page numbers of books.
Roman numerals are still used widely in modern culture,
but they're only used at times when you use numbers, not for mathematics.
So dates, page numbers, chapter numbers,
Superbowls, things like that. So you could quite easily do the Superbowl and,
um, Cistercian numbers. Maybe you could do some, I know.
Is there any kind of the Catholic Olympic games or something they could use that.
It's a cool system. Isn't that really cool?
This is highest or room and
is toilet because it's the shame house.
A barn is cow eyes.
Shame, shame house. Yeah. Excuse me. Can I ask where to show them houses.